noël que l'on travaille pour le journal
l'éléphant déchaîné il a mené l'enquêté
sur le volet ivoirien des pandora
peppers nous avons pendant près de deux
ans
analyser la base de données que nos
partenaires haïtiens qui a bien voulu
mettre à notre disposition
et lorsque nous avons épluché ses
dossiers au niveau de la côte d'ivoire
nous avons eu à constater que plusieurs
autorités sont détenteurs de sociétés
offshore et avait une barrière
linguistique les documents la plupart
étaient en anglais mais à force de
persévérance
j'ai fini par découvrir que le premier
ministre patrick achi a créé une société
offshore qui était basé aux bahamas donc
ça a été vraiment le
l'élément le plus essentiel dans cette
enquête mais il n'est pas le seul il ya
le médiateur de la république adama
toungara mais pour les autres acteurs
comme on n'a pas encore commencé à
étudier sur le dossier je préférais sous
le permettez ne pas encore citer de noms
l issue de cette enquête ils ne sont pas
y avoir de faits concrets pour
incriminer réellement le premier
ministre et on ne sait pas si sa société
a été active jusqu'à sa fermeture en
2006 mais le journaliste ivoirien relève
des difficultés pour accéder à de
nombreux documents il ya eu quelques
difficultés rendent vers l'événement de
cette enquête c'est que il ya des
institutions qui devrait nous faciliter
la tâche dans la collecte de données
comme la haute autorité de la bonne
gouvernance où nos autorités sont
censées faire la déclaration de leur
patrimoine mais leurs déclarations sont
confidentielles patrick achi a réagi et
a démenti toute action illégale mais le
journaliste pointe surtout et les
questions d'éthique que soulève son
investigation créer une société offshore
en soi c'est pas un acte illégal mais là
où il ya un problème c'est un problème
d'éthique sadi une prime une autorité de
ce pays
qui est certainement qui bénéficient des
avantages du contribuable et qui ne crée
pas une société su placer ceux qui
décident d'aller faire une optimisation
fiscale dans un paradis fiscal j'ai un
problème d'éthique est ce qu'ils donnent
le bon exemple à ses concitoyens que
nous sommes nous subissons une pression
fiscale mais on fait de notre mieux pour
pouvoir
rempli ses obligations pourquoi est ce
que eux il ne peut pas faire la même
chose ils utilisent des voies détournées
pour échapper au fisc ivoiriens cette
enquête a valu à noël qu'au nom des
pressions de sa hiérarchie et une
campagne de dénigrement et moi je mène
une enquête je savais quelle question je
voulais poser au premier ministre pour
confirmer ou infirmer cette information
mais mon patron qui va le rencontrer
sans m'informer et qui vient par la
suite mais dit que le premier ministre
souhaiterait que l' enquête ne fassent
pas l'objet de publications j'étais
encore à une phase où l' enquête n'était
pas encore bouclée mais les réactions de
venant de mon patron et menace la peur
d'être sur écoute ou d'être suivie
aujourd'hui le journaliste grand pour sa
sécurité j'essaie de faire attention à
ma sortie maintenant
j'observe si je vois que ma sécurité est
vraiment compromise j'ai demandé
récemment asile pour quitter mon pays la
côte d'ivoire et le journaliste ivoirien
assure avoir les identités de beaucoup
d'autres personnalités il se dit
déterminé a publié plusieurs documents
dans les jours qui viennent et ce malgré
les pressions